sony has revealed key details of an
upcoming 3.5 hour firmware update set to
deploy soon to the PlayStation 4 it
includes a number of long requested
features I'm Lucy and welcome to this
appearing offline gamespot news update
with 3.5 oh you'll finally be able to
appear offline while you're connected to
the PlayStation Network you can choose
to appear offline when you log in or you
can change your online status from your
profile or in the Quick Menu also added
to the feature list is remote play on PC
or Mac which will allow players to
connect that PlayStation 4 with a
desktop computer within the same home
network allowing them to play
playstation 4 games on another screen or
in another room in the house previously
remote play was a feature that only
worked on PlayStation Vita an assortment
of Sony smartphones and the recently
discontinued micro consult PlayStation
TV other new social features to come in
the firmware update include friend
online notifications the ability to live
stream directly to dailymotion as well
as a feature called play together that
lets all members of a party see what
everyone else is playing finally we've
user sheduled event you'll be able to
schedule a gameplay session with your
friends and then when the event starts
all those who registered to take part
will be automatically added to a party
to start playing straight away sony says
the pizza for the 3.5 hour update which
has been codenamed Musashi will roll out
soon to select customers and official
release date has yet to be announced so
what do you make of the update anything
that you really want that Sony hasn't
added yet let me know in the comments or
combine me on Twitter I'm at Lucy James
games for all the latest ps4 news keep a
gamespot
you